Me pidieron que viniera aquí para hablar sobre creación.
Sólo tengo 15 minutos y veo que ya están corriendo.
Y puedo, en 15 minutos, creo que sólo puedo tocar una rama muy prosaica de la creación,
a la cual llamo creatividad.
La creatividad es la forma en que lidiamos con la creación.
Mientras la creación a veces parece un poco incomprensible, o incluso carente de sentido
la creatividad siempre es significativa.
Por ejemplo, vean esta fotografía.
Saben, la creación es la que colocó a ese perro en esa foto
y la creatividad es la que nos hace ver a un pollo en sus cuartos traseros.
Cuando lo piensan, la creatividad también tiene mucho que ver con la causalidad.
Saben, de adolescente, yo era un creador.
Simplemente hacía cosas.
Luego me hice adulto y comencé a saber quién era
y traté de preservar a esa persona, me volví creativo.
No fue hasta que hice un libro y una exposición retrospectiva, que pude rastrear exactamente...
parece como si todas las cosas más locas que he hecho, todas mis borracheras, todas mis fiestas,
siguieron una línea recta que me llevaron al punto
en que, en efecto, les estoy hablando en este momento.
Aunque esto realmente es verdad, saben,
la razón por la que estoy hablándoles ahora mismo es porque nací en Brasil.
Si hubiese nacido en Monterey, probablemente estaría en Brasil.
Saben, nací en Brasil y crecí en los años 70
en un clima de tensión política,
y me vi obligado a aprender a comunicarme de un modo muy específico,
en una suerte de mercado negro de la semiótica.
No podías decir lo que realmente querías decir,
tenías que inventar formas de hacerlo.
No tenías mucha confianza en la información.
Eso me llevó a otro paso en el porqué estoy hoy aquí,
es porque me encantaban todo tipo de medios de comunicación.
Era un adicto a los medios y con el tiempo me metí en la publicidad.
Mi primer trabajo en Brasil,
de hecho, fue desarrollar un método para mejorar la legibilidad de las vallas
basado en velocidad, ángulo de aproximación y bloques de texto.
Fue muy... de hecho, fue un estudio muy bueno
y me hizo obtener trabajo en una agencia publicitaria.
Y además, decidieron que debía tener...
que debían darme un feo trofeo de acrílico por ello.
Otra razón -- por la que estoy aquí --
es porque el día que fui a recoger el trofeo de acrílico,
renté un esmoquin por primera vez en mi vida,
recogí aquella cosa... no tenía amigos.
Camino a la salida, tuve que detener una pelea.
Alguien estaba golpeando con manoplas a otra persona.
Estaban de esmoquin y peleando, fue horrible.
Y además, -- la gente de la publicidad hace eso todo el tiempo(risas)
y yo... bueno, lo que sucedió es que cuando regresaba, iba de regreso a mi auto,
el tipo golpeado decidió empuñar un revólver
--no sé porque tenía una pistola--
y dispararle a la primera persona que decidió que era su agresor.
A la primera persona vistiendo de etiqueta, de esmoquin. Fue a mí.
Afortunadamente, no fue fatal, como todos pueden ver.
Y, para mayor suerte, el tipo dijo estar apenado
y lo chantajeé por una compensación económica o de lo contrario le denunciaría.
Y es así cómo --con este dinero compré un boleto a los Estados Unidos en 1983,
y esa es la razón básica por la que estoy hoy aquí.
Porque me dispararon. (Risas) (Aplausos).
Bueno, cuando empecé a hacer mis propias obras, decidí que no debería hacer imágenes.
Saben, me convertí... tomé este enfoque muy iconoclasta.
Porque cuando decidí entrar a la publicidad, yo quería hacer...
deseaba aerografiar desnudos en hielo, para anuncios de whisky,
eso es lo que en realidad quería hacer.
Pero yo -- no me dejaron hacerlo, así que yo sólo, ya saben,
sólo me permitían hacer otras cosas.
Pero yo no tenía interés en vender whisky, tenía interés en vender hielo.
Las primeras obras en realidad fueron objetos.
Eran una suerte de mezcla de objetos encontrados, diseño de productos y publicidad.
Y les llamé reliquias.
Se exhibieron por primera vez en la Galería Stux en 1983.
Esta es la Calavera de Payaso.
Es un vestigio de una raza, de una raza muy evolucionada de entretenedores.
Vivieron en Brasil hace mucho tiempo. (Risas)
Éste es el joystick Ashanti.
Desafortunadamente, se volvió obsoleto porque fue diseñado para la plataforma Atari.
Está por venir un Playstation II, quizá para el próximo TED lo traiga.
El Podio Mecedor. (Risas)
Ésta es la Cafetera Precolombina. (Risas)
De hecho, la idea surgió de una discusión que tuve en un Starbuck's,
yo insistía en que no estaba tomando café colombiano,
sino que en realidad era precolombino.
La Mesa Bonsái.
Toda la Enciclopedia Británica encuadernada en un único tomo para viajeros.
Y la Media Lápida, para la gente que aún no ha muerto.
Quise llevar aquello al mundo de las imágenes,
y decidí hacer cosas que tuvieran los mismos conflictos de identidad.
Así que decidí trabajar con nubes.
Porque las nubes pueden ser todo lo que desees.
Pero ahora quería trabajar con tecnología muy básica,
por lo tanto, algo que pudiera ser al mismo tiempo
un bulto de algodón, una nube y unas manos en oración de Durero,
aunque éstas se parecen mucho más a las manos en oración de Mickey Mouse.
Pero aún estaba, saben, esta es una nube minina.
Se llaman "Equivalentes", por la obra de Alfred Stieglitz.
"El Caracol".
Pero aún seguía trabajando en escultura,
y en realidad estaba tratando de hacer cosas cada vez más planas.
"La Tetera".
Tuve oportunidad de ir a Florencia, en... creo que en el 94,
y vi "Las Puertas del Paraíso" de Ghiberthi.
Y él hizo algo muy difícil.
Ensambló dos medios diferentes provenientes de épocas distintas.
Primero, consiguió un método antiguo para hacerlo, el relieve
y lo trabajó con la perspectiva de tres puntos, que era una nueva tecnología en ese entonces.
Y es completamente demoledor.
Y tus ojos no saben a qué nivel mirar.
Y quedas atrapado en este tipo de representación.
Y así que decidí hacer estas bastante sencillas representaciones,
que al principio se perciben como un dibujo lineal.
Saben, algo muy... y luego lo hice con alambre.
La idea era --porque todos omiten el blanco-- como los dibujos a lápiz ¿no?
Y al mirarlo, "¡Ah! Es un dibujo a lápiz".
Entonces tienes esta reacción retardada y ves que en realidad es algo que existió en el tiempo.
Que tuvo materialidad,
y comienzas a adentrarte más y más en una suerte de narrativa
que va en esta dirección, hacia la imagen. Así surgieron "Mono con Leica".
"Relajación".
"Fiat Lux".
Y del mismo modo, el historial de representación
evolucionó del dibujo lineal al dibujo sombreado.
Y yo deseaba abarcar otros temas.
Empecé a tomarlos del mundo del paisaje,
los cuales son algo como casi un cuadro de nada.
Hice estos cuadros llamados Cuadros de Hilo,
y el nombre surgió por la cantidad de yardas que utilicé para representar cada cuadro.
Al final estos siempre terminaban siendo una foto
o más bien como un grabado en este caso.
Así que este es un faro.
Este es "6.500 Yardas" por Corot, "9.000 Yardas" por Gerhard Richter.
Y no sé cuántas yardas por John Constable.
Alejándome de las líneas, decidí abordar la idea de los puntos,
como algo más similar al tipo de representación que hallamos en las propias fotografías.
Conocí un grupo de niños en la isla caribeña de San Kitts,
con quienes trabajé y jugué.
Les tomé algunas fotos.
A mi llegada a Nueva York, decidí...
eran hijos de trabajadores de plantaciones de caña azucarera
y mediante la manipulación de azúcar sobre papel negro, hice sus retratos.
Son estos (aplausos)
Gracias. Esta es "Valentina, la más rápida".
Sólo era el nombre de la niña,
con ese poco que llegas a saber de alguien que apenas conociste.
"Valicia".
"Jacynthe".
Pero había todavía otra capa de representación.
Porque estaba haciendo esto cuando realizaba estas imágenes
y me dñi cuenta de que todavía podía agregar otra cosa,
estaba intentando hacer un sujeto
algo que interfiriese con los temas,
para lo que el chocolat...e es muy bueno, porque tiene
evoca pensamientos que van de la escatología al romance.
De esta manera decidí hacer estos cuadros
y eran muy grandes, por lo que tenías que alejarte de ellos para poder verlos.
Así que se llaman Cuadros de Chocolate.
Quizás Freud podría explicar el chocolate mejor que yo. Él fue el primer sujeto.
Y Jackson Pollock también.
Los cuadros de multitudes son particularmente interesantes,
porque, saben, te acercas a aquello...
tratas de resolver el umbral con algo que puedas identificar muy fácilmente,
como una cara, que se va convirtiendo en sólo una textura.
"Paparazzi".
Usé polvo del Museo Whitney para representar algunas piezas de su colección.
Y escogí piezas minimalistas porque tratan sobre la especificidad.
Y representas esto con el más inespecífico de los materiales,
el polvo mismo.
Como, ya saben, tienen las partículas cutáneas de cada visitante del museo.
Si hicieran un análisis de ADN de esto, saldrían con una enorme lista de correos.
Este es Richard Serra.
Compré una computadora y me dijeron que tiene millones de colores.
Saben, la primera reacción de un artista a eso es: ¿quién los contó?
Y me di cuenta de que nunca trabajé con color,
porque pasé por una etapa difícil controlando la idea de colores únicos.
Pero si se aplica principalmente a estructuras numéricas,
entonces puedes sentirte más cómodo.
Así que la primera vez que trabajé con colores fue para hacer estos mosaicos con muestras de Pantone.
Terminaron siendo cuadros muy grandes,
que fotografié con una enorme cámara,
una cámara de 8x10.
De modo que ves la superficie de cada muestra
como en este cuadro de Chuck Close.
Y tienes que alejarte mucho para poder verlo.
Además, la referencia al uso de paletas cromáticas de Gerhard Richter
y también la idea de entrar en otro ámbito de representación que hoy en día nos es muy común,
el mapa de bits.
Acabé limitando el tema a "Los Almiares" de Monet.
Esto es algo que hacía como en broma,
ya saben, hacer -- algo como -- "Malecón Espiral" de Robert Smithson
y entonces dejar rastros, como si se hubiera hecho sobre una mesa.
Intentaba demostrar que él no construyó esa cosa en Salt Lake.
Pero entones, con sólo hacer los modelos, estaba tratando de explorar la relación
entre el modelo y el original.
Y sentí que realmente tendría que ir allá y realizar yo mismo algunos trabajos en tierra.
Opté por dibujos lineales muy simples, de aspecto un poco estúpido.
Y, al mismo tiempo, estaba haciendo estas enormes construcciones,
a 150 metros de distancia.
Ahora haría unas muy pequeñas, que serían como...
pero bajo la misma luz y las expondría juntas,
de modo que el espectador tendría que descifrar cuál de ellas estaba mirando.
No estaba interesado en las cosas muy grandes o en las muy pequeñas.
Me interesaban más las cosas intermedias,
saben, porque puedes dejar allí un enorme rango de ambigüedad.
Esto es como lo ven, el tamaño de una persona aquí.
Esta es una pipa.
Un gancho de ropa.
Y aquí está otra cosa que hice, saben, al trabajar
a todos nos gusta mirar a alguien dibujar,
pero no mucha gente tiene la oportunidad de mirar a alguien dibujando
a mucha gente al mismo tiempo, que presencie un único dibujo.
Y me encanta este trabajo,
porque durante dos meses hice estas nubes de caricatura sobre Manhattan.
Y fue maravilloso porque tenía un interés -- un interés precoz -- en el teatro
que está justificado en esta cosa.
En teatro, tienes al personaje y al actor en el mismo lugar,
tratando de negociar entre sí, frente a una audiencia.
Y en esto, tendrías como un...
algo que se parece a una nube y es, a la vez, una nube.
Así que son como actores perfectos.
Mi interés en la actuación, en especial la mala actuación, viene de mucho tiempo atrás.
De hecho, en una ocasión pagué 60 dólares
para ver a un gran actor hacer una versión del Rey Lear,
y sentí que me robaron, porque para cuando el actor se convirtió en el Rey Lear,
dejó de ser el gran actor por el que había pagado para ver.
Por otro lado, saben, pagué como tres dólares, creo,
y fui a una bodega en Queens
para ver una versión de Otelo montado por un grupo aficionado.
Y fue completamente fascinante porque el tipo,
su nombre era Joey Grimaldi,
personificó al general moro...
durante los tres primeros minutos, en verdad fue aquel general,
y luego volvió a ser el plomero, era un plomero, así que
plomero, general, plomero, general,
por tres dólares, vi dos tragedias por el precio de una.
Vean, pienso que en realidad no se trata de impresión,
de hacer que la gente caiga por una ilusión realmente perfecta,
tanto como hacer -- habitualmente trabajo en el umbral inferior de la ilusión visual.
Porque no se trata de engañar a alguien,
sino, en realidad, de darle una medida de sus propias creencias:
qué tanto desean ser engañados.
Por eso pagamos para ver espectáculos de magia y cosas así.
Bueno, creo que eso es todo.
Mi tiempo ya casi se acaba.
Muchísimas gracias.